foreign
hey you guys what's going on happy
Sunday and we're doing a movie review
yep we're finally finally getting ready
to do Black Hawk Down because Louie sent
us this movie yeah several weeks ago
like he sent us this one in Highlander
so we already did Highlander like a
couple weeks back but we just hadn't got
around to doing Black Hawk Down yet
because we just hadn't had time to watch
it and stuff like that but finally we
watched it last night it said Blu-ray
4K and then a bonus disc which we
haven't seen the bonus disc yet but it's
probably a bunch of historical stuff and
then documentaries on making it this is
a [__] great movie
it is yeah this is I actually don't
think I don't think I saw this when it
came out and I had forgotten how old
this movie was it came out in 2001 yeah
which uh is crazy which actually was
only eight years after the actual
incident that it is inspired by yeah
it's all-star cast
all-star cast and I didn't realize Tom
Hardy was in this I didn't notice him he
played uh twombly okay yeah I didn't
notice him like one of those yeah yeah
yeah and I was just kind of I didn't
recognize him either because like I said
they got you know everybody had helmets
on and they were all dirty and bloody
and stuff like that so it's like kind of
like I recognized a lot of the actors
like Tom Sizemore and obviously Ewan
McGregor and uh Eric Bana and some other
people like that but I didn't realize it
was Tom Hardy until it went down this
was actually his first uh movie because
this was before he got real famous
Orlando Bloom was in this too I don't
think it was Orlando Bloom's first movie
but um but he this was kind of before he
was like super famous also this um this
movie as far as war movies goes on par
with Apocalypse Now in terms of quality
it's not the tone is very different you
know it's not as uh say artistic or
stylistic or symbolic you know the way
um uh
Apocalypse Now was but it's just as epic
it's pretty long
and it's all just the [__] mission
that they were doing there's a little
bit of build up they introduce you to
the guys as they start you know start
off their version you know their parts
in the mission but it's just the mission
and what a cluster [__] it was
now this movie
is about a time when I was in service
I was in service with 101st Airborne
Division the first and 327 recomplitude
and they came Mi came and interviewed us
for something we didn't know what it was
but it was Operation restore hope which
is that's what this was about operation
restore hope
and they were just asking us crazy
questions they came dressed in civilian
clothes so you didn't know what rank
of the person was you were talking to
they were just trying to get you to
speak freely
and they would ask us where they were
asking us questions at a platoon level
they were like what would happen and
then they broke down also down to Squad
levels and asked guys at Squad levels
questions
and they were just asking questions like
what if you were in a place and there
was a building
and people in the building were shooting
at you
and inside that building were friendly
civilians
how would you handle that situation they
were just crazy stuff like that
and we told them the truth we were like
oh yeah we we know what you're talking
about friendly civilians mixed with
enemy
in the same country
and and we were like that doesn't happen
it says because if you kill some of
those guys the friendlies turn on you
because they're all related
so we called it and you know there were
guys in my opportunity that just were
just laying it down
they're like what you're talking about
is [__] don't go over there you
don't if you say if you wanna if you
send us we're going to annihilate them
all we're gonna blow that whole building
down
it says you know this is that kind of
situation you don't send us
and they didn't they didn't set us they
sent us to Egypt instead
to do the mfo mission
and while I was in that mfo mission that
was about six months
we heard that this had happened
I was up on op311.
Eric and Ross man they shot down a whole
bunch of helicopters down in in
Mogadishu it was like what oh yeah man
one helicopter after another they were
trying to come and rescue the guys they
just kept shooting down more helicopters
and then about a week later
we were able to see video of like
dudes from Mogadishu dancing with body
parts of the [__] helicopter pilots
and stuff
now the pilots in this
were from task force 160 Special
Operations at Aviation that was my
uncle's unit his name was cw3 Frost
he was a little bird pilot
and he he was in on this I don't know if
he was in this actual Mission but he
went to Mogadishu he wouldn't tell me
because
task force 160 that they're working with
that sfod or Delta and SF
and they just don't talk about anything
he was just a wild dude now he's a
bodyguard and helicopter pilot for an
emir over in [__] UAE or something
dude's a little bit older than me and
just [__] shredded
pushing 60 looks [__] great
but so this
story I'm kind of parallel to this
I'm watching it all the equipment I'm
recognizing it
some of it I'm not recognizing oh those
are Marines you know
but it's a wild movie man it's good real
good
and it goes down fairly accurately
from based on memory of what had
happened I mean more or less there were
some stuff they changed around which
they did actually get criticized for I
think one of the main criticisms Ridley
Scott directed this yeah actually one of
his good movies and uh well a lot of his
movies are good some of them this is the
one this is the one that he did after
Gladiator yeah like you know this was
the one he made after Gladiator yeah and
he actually got four Oscar nominations
for this like a Best Director when it's
up he won two I think it was best sound
editing and some one other one but uh
this did win some Oscars and like made
some okay money and got like good
critical notices and stuff but it did
get criticized for some of the stuff
they changed I mean one of a couple of
things they changed that you know
obviously you would just have to for
because it's based on a book that was
written by a journalist who was embedded
and he was there and he saw a bunch of
this stuff happen but it's kind of like
um you know obviously they had to winnow
down like the kind of hundred or so key
figures in the actual thing like down to
about 39 characters in this so some of
the people were you know conglomerations
of several characters they did that
um Somalia the somalis were uh
particularly called for a boycott
because uh one they were mad because no
Somali actors uh were actually used in
this which uh they thought was and there
were no
um
Somali like uh there was nobody that was
like Consulting on the movie like you
know to kind of give their perspective
or anything and a lot of them were mad
at the way that the it made them all
just look like a bunch of savages so
they were kind of pissed off about that
some of the actual somalis that were
portrayed in the movie like the guy at
the beginning that was captured like
he's like I'm nothing like that that's
not how the situation was so there's
that kind of [__] and I don't know so I
kind of feel like that was the main uh
criticism of it and like I said they
changed around some of the things but
more or less it's pretty accurate to
what happened like kind of you know what
I'm saying but I mean the thing about it
though is that the way it's shot this
movie it's just like it [__] it's
almost kind of like the way he shot it's
not I don't want to say it's like
documentary style because actually the
cinematography in this is quite
beautiful and that was one of the um one
of the Oscar nominations that I got was
best cinematographers didn't win I think
Lord of the Rings won but it was
nominated anyway because I was
commenting on I was like ah the
cinematography and this is gorgeous but
the way he shot it it was almost kind of
like you were an embedded journalist it
was very much like a like you were there
and so it was like really the whole
thing was like really really tense
and you have to think too uh I think
this was a big influence on um Call of
Duty because Call of Duty the video
games did not come out until after this
movie okay so I think that this was kind
of one of the things that they were
homaging you know what I'm saying it's
very accurate to the times yeah the feel
of it that's it and the look that's the
way it looked that's what it felt to be
in service in any kind of air assault or
Airborne infantry or Delta SF Task Force
160 all those guys anything out of brag
or Campbell this in those days this is
what it pretty much looked like it had
Marines in there too
with their 20-inch ARs and
they're some of their equipment's a
little bit different just the way that
they did things was a little bit
different but the army guys yeah that's
it
that's it
yeah so I was impressed with kind of
like the accuracy the visual accuracy
and the accuracy of the the culture of
the time the Army culture was like that
well they did have all the actors
um that were playing their respective
characters they actually did meet the
people and like hung out with them and
yeah they put them through like the
Ranger school and everything like that
so it's like they like I said it seemed
like they tried to get it as accurate as
it was possible to make it while still
like making it a good movie you know
what I'm saying yeah
it was a different time as before Molly
everything was like in it was they were
still using Alice type equipment and
mixed in with uh some of the new LBVS
and
guys were wearing black one-piece kind
of lbv style Body Armor that I'd never
really seen that that was something the
task force was wearing at the time
just the helmets the [__] the birds
that they were flying that was it yeah
it's good man they called it that that's
exactly it the weaponry
and I liked one of the things I liked
about it is when they showed any of the
ARs
from the Marines or
one task force a couple things from task
force that I think they got wrong but
um but when they were showing the uh
Rangers and [__]
their weapons were all beaten up and
that's the way they really looked
there's a lot on all the high spots on
the upper and lower receivers of ARS
we're just ground down to the aluminum
so it was shiny it was black and not
black they were dark gray and silver
a lot of silver highlights because every
angle was worn down to the metal to the
aluminum and a lot of times when they
have these war movies it's a brand new
out of the box weapon
there's no aluminum showing like
something that came out just right out
of the box nobody had well it probably
did because we just ordered the problem
[Laughter]
but these look like real wet it's a real
real army weapons
SF or whatever they're beating up
looking
because it was kind of a
kind of a uh
status symbol to have equipment that was
kind of beating up looking you didn't
want to look like you just came out of
basic Trinity well yeah everything was
worn and beaten up you can see yeah you
can see yeah like that [__]
works yeah he works for a living dude
that's that kind of [__]
so everything we have is just beaten up
it worked though
you know or you wouldn't be carrying it
now one thing I noticed that was wrong I
think it was wrong
because I wasn't in task force 160 but
one of the task force guys
he gets knocked out of the bird and he's
got an MP5 and it's a collapsible stock
short brailed MP5 it's not a k though
it's an MP MP5 and he does a little
action with that and during that time
I don't think task force had that weapon
they had another MP5 at that time that
was a PDW or personal defense weapon it
had a side folding stock on it
and I think it had a slight I think it
had a a small foregrip
and I even think it might have had a
flashlight and it went in a leg holster
a low slug leg holster
and I didn't see any of those in this
movie but I remember that they had those
so I think that might have been a maybe
they couldn't get that weapon yeah I
mean that seems like a pretty minor yeah
thing like to get wrong if it indeed it
was wrong yeah it was like an MP5K
it has slightly different front end
front end on it and it had a side
folding stock
that's what it looked like
um and I think it even I think you could
put a suppressor on there I think there
and they had a shorter mag and it all
went into a leg holster it was too big
for that leg holster I'm telling you but
they did it they were Chopper Pilots it
was not like they were running around
they just wanted to make sure that they
could fly fly a chopper and if they got
thrown out of the chopper or the wreck
that they could get out of there and
they'd have a weapon on them that they
could use
which in this particular movie
it's a good thing that's exactly what
happens he's kind of thrown from a
chopper and he's got something with him
to fight with he runs out of ammo though
gets captured grafter says uh grandther
has known some special forces guys two
things one they don't talk much about
their trade and never ever bragged about
[__] two they weren't big muscle head
bow hunks they were small wiry guys yeah
right prior to uh live streaming I was
watching a documentary about the battle
of Mogadishu because I don't remember a
lot like I remember the broad outlines
and I read a book about it like a long
time ago like but um I didn't remember a
lot of the details so I read and they
had a lot of the guys like the real guys
that were there and that that was one
thing I noted they were all like kind of
yeah like small yeah dude yeah they look
like small wiry dudes you know with
glasses and stuff like that they weren't
like real big uh like Meathead looking
dudes or anything like that and um it
was like pretty [__] uh terrifying
like listen to their story about it and
I also kind of they kind of go into this
at the beginning of the movie where they
give you kind of like an extended like
text thing which is kind of like giving
you some context like for you know what
the Battle of mogadishi like what uh
kind of caused it but I don't remember
if they said they're like prior to
um you know the late like the early
1990s it seemed like uh they were they
had like a humanitarian efforts going on
there because there was a lot of
Warlords and like they you know the Red
Cross and stuff would send the food
because of the um you know all the Civil
War was causing uh Mass starvation so
they were caught they were sending food
there and then a like a lot of the
Warlords were stealing the food
um you know so they could use it to pay
their soldiers and blah blah and so all
these people were starving and so all
these countries got involved un got
involved and they were trying to get the
food to the starving people and for a
time no one was really taking a side
like with any of the Warlords and
consequently uh most of the people in
Somalia were okay with um you know the
the various troops being there whether
they were Americans or pakistanis or
whoever
but then it happened that the warlord
who's kind of like at the center of this
movie like the thing that happened here
I did
um he let his behest apparently and they
think maybe Al Qaeda was involved too
ended up killing some Pakistani
peacekeepers at which point the American
government so we need to crack down on
this [__] and like bring him in and
then it seemed like a lot of somalis
said perceived that we were taking sides
then and that they didn't want the
Americans there they didn't want the U.N
there and so they started like fighting
back against them yeah now having been
in this business
whatever the Army tells you the mission
is and they told us it was basically
what she said
we're going to hand out food to these
people you know then Warlords are
stopping us from handing out food to
these people we knew that was a cover
story all right they never tell you the
real reason that's what they tell the
army
so you'll shut the [__] up and just do
the mission and that's what they tell
civilians that's just a cover story
there was another reason why they wanted
to get in there
it's just that they don't let us know
you'll probably never know it probably
had to do they wanted to get in there
and destroy Al Qaeda it's probably all
it was because there was some relation
there they found out later that there
was a link up between but they can't
come out and say we're going to get
involved in this other country and a
bunch of y'all are going to get killed
and we're going to destroy Al Qaeda it
won't make a difference but we'll make a
bunch of money off of contracts and then
once we have that place we can use it as
a launch pad to jump out and do it again
somewhere else it's Empire Building
definitely
but it's never what they tell you it is
it's like weapons of mass destruction
get the [__] out of here
liberation of Kuwait come on that that
was not that that had nothing to do with
any of that that's the cover story that
that's what they tell the people to get
them to accept the war the real reason
is always veiled
I mean the thing about this one and we
were talking about this like after the
movie was over and I think that was one
of the reasons why it took us so long to
win not only because this movie is like
quite long it's like two and a half
hours and we didn't have like a long
enough chunk of time to watch it but I
was like I know that this movie is going
to be a bummer
um and it was like it's it's [__] up
to say it's like entertaining it is an
entertaining movie in the sense that
it's like really tense and it really
like gets you involved and like in the
action and stuff but it's ultimately a
downer because one not only is it based
on a true story and a bunch of horrific
[__] [__] happened
um but also because it was ultimately
and I was watching the documentary
before and like some of the guys that
were really there they said oh you know
some of the parents of the people that
the soldiers that were killed there were
like you know did my son die for nothing
and you know and they're like well we
don't like to think of it like that
because it's you know everybody showed
bravery and so which they did but I just
don't know I mean they shouldn't have
been there in the first place and that
like makes me really sad that this whole
[__] cluster [__] didn't have to
happen because the thing about it is
that their mission simply was to get
well simply was to go into they had
Intel that I did and his uh some of his
generals and stuff were going to be at
this hotel they're having a big meeting
and so they were going to go in there
and capture a couple of the guys and it
was supposed to be really easy and the
thing about it is that when I was
watching the documentary like the guys
that were actually in the mission they
said well at first it was really easy
like we just got in there it was no
problem we got the prisoners we got the
guys we were supposed to get we got him
in the Convoy and then a few minutes
later uh one of the Blackhawks got shot
down by an RPG
and uh at that point everything went
horribly horribly sideways
um because essentially everyone in like
all the somalis and mogadishi were like
fighting back against them another
helicopter got shot down they couldn't
get to the people because like some of
the people were like some of the
soldiers in the um in the Blackhawk were
killed outright but some of them were
just wounded and so you know they're
Rangers they don't leave anybody even if
you're dead they're gonna go in there
and get your body so it's like it was
just this battle and that's what the
whole movie is about it's just this one
I think how long was the battle was it
like 17 18 hours something like that and
like so they're basically just like
fighting through these [__] with all
this Urban Warfare trying to get to this
helicopter that crashed like to get the
people back out of it and they're just
being [__] shot at and blown up and
[__] like that and it's just horrifying
like just the whole thing is just so
it's it's just so tense like sitting
there watching it and they really did a
good job with um too with the realism of
the injuries especially that one where
like the dude gets his hand shot yeah
and like is it going yeah and that what
yeah well the real guy like um that was
on there he he said that he saw that guy
he saw that happen and he's like you
could see him running down the street
and you could see his thumb was just
like flopping against his arm like that
and it's like you could see what was all
[__] up but he got like his gun shot
out of his hand and it just like [__]
blew his hand up yeah [__] went down
exactly like we told him was that it was
going to go down that it didn't matter
it didn't matter what they said if you
went down there and you killed anybody
then they would all turn against you and
that's exactly what happened pretty much
yeah pretty much the whole city that's
just the way it is okay race is a factor
if you have some white people show up
you just kill some black people be the
same thing if if some black people
showed up and killed a bunch of white
people from they're all from different
countries they're all just gonna [__]
fight they're all gonna fight the in the
foreign Invader it doesn't matter who
was stealing the food or who was right
or wrong they just they're all related
you kill one of them you're killing
[__] family members and [__]
you know what I mean they're not going
to sit there and let you kill some of
their guys they don't care that they're
Warlords they don't care that they've
been stealing it's just not in human
nature so we called it we knew exactly
how it was going to go down and I
guarantee you am I knew exactly that
that's how it would go down and they
were dependent on it to go down that way
they knew they knew it would do that
they just didn't realize it's gonna be
that difficult
they were probably like yeah it'll get
into a fight where we're gonna have to
fight them all but they're not going to
be very good Fighters and it'll it'll
justify us wiping them out then we could
we could have a large that's why how
that happened that's not how it has it
but that's what they were thinking yeah
that's what they were thinking never
never
never take the mission at face value
they're always giving you the cover
story
because it's hot it's
it's high security the truth is the
truth is top secret
they're just going to give you the
[__] cover story and and it's going
to be the same cover story they're given
to the American public
and it's [__] and that's exactly
what happens there's this whole thing
was [__] [__] they didn't feed
anybody
and who they were going to feed turned
out to be their enemies anyway
and there was nothing to be gained there
as far as we knew
dudes got killed 19 people got yeah
there was on our side like and they
don't know how many somalis got killed
all kinds of Bravery [__] happened and
dudes showing their skills and showing
how awesome they were as soldiers all
for nothing
and then they all just laughed
and you know
if anybody ever tells you if anybody
ever tells you well you'll never defeat
the American Army with [__] an
assault rifle you're full of [__] that's
who's been whipping our asses for
[__] 40 years man dudes well adiq
[__] and flip-flops and [__]
AKs have been whipping our asses for
[__] decades that's how you do it you
know just resist you know what's crazy
yeah and actually like I said the
documentary I was just watching like one
of the actual guys that was there who
they interviewed
um you know he was young then obviously
like when he was going through this and
he said that as soon as he's like you
know the mission seemed easy at first
everything was going the way it was
supposed to go we got the guys we were
supposed to get we were gonna leave and
then when the helicopter got shot down
he said the first thing he thought was
like this isn't how they're supposed to
go where the Americans yeah you know
he's and like the fact that he said that
he admitted that he thought that like
you know if he thought everything was
gonna be and they kind of like show that
in the movie too where they're just
gonna like oh it's gonna be a piece of
piss you know it's gonna be super easy
we're gonna go in and out there's 30
minutes tops we'll be back here in an
hour you know what I mean and yeah
that's not how that went down no well
because they kind of
I don't know they seem to like kind of
underestimate like I said all it took
was like one dude like on a roof and
there was tons of people like just tons
of somalis that were on the roofs they
were in the every alley and it's like
they all had heavy Weaponry they all had
RPGs they all and so all it took was for
them to shoot down one Blackhawk in the
middle of like this alley and then they
couldn't get to it everybody was lost
like they had this other dude the other
dudes like up in this other Blackhawk
like trying to tell everybody where it
was because they couldn't see it and
they're like everywhere they went they
were just getting [__] shot at and
then now the the the you know helicopter
was down everybody knew like all the
somalis knew where that was so it's like
they wanted to prevent people from
getting there they were trying to like
you know so they're building like
roadblocks like at the end of alleys and
[__] like that and just ambushing the
convoys that were trying to come in
there and like save everybody
101st didn't tell them what they wanted
to hear we told him says no that's a
cluster [__] we'll never do that you
sent us there we're gonna kill everybody
so they were like [__] no we're not
gonna send another first
and that was E4 and Below was telling
them that
but then the cut the units that actually
volunteered for it said they would go
they were the biggest [__] ass
kissing years they're good units but
they're ass kisses Rangers will tell
them anything oh yes sir we can do that
oh yes sir we're we're Rangers we can do
that they won't even ask SF or Delta or
anything they'll just go they'd do
anything they're told
10th Mountain went because 10th Mountain
they're a good unit they're cluster [__]
up in the mountains yeah sure we can do
that Marines oh they're always gonna say
yeah we could do that we're the Marine
men no no
I mean you have to kind of know when no
you have to know what your weaknesses
are yeah like you have to know where to
cut your loss no because this just went
like I said all it took was that one
helicopter being shot down and then
everything just started going very very
well for us in in the business the whole
friendly and enemy mixture
angle will the enemy in the friendlies
will be mixed together when we're like
no no they won't be mixed together
they're all enemy well what do you mean
they're all enemy well if the if the
enemy is firing at you and the
friendlies are with them not killing the
enemy then they're all enemy they're not
helping us so they're enemy and that's
exactly what the Army at that time am I
did not want to hear that this is no if
they're not helping us they're enemy if
we were right
[__] right we were like don't send us
in there you crazy
yeah
he said well if you have snipers in the
building and you have all these women
and children we're going to call our
artillery strike on that building
yeah because you know and [__]
there's an NCO saying well I'd rather
kill a whole bunch of civilians than get
one of my guys killed I mean they're
foreign civilians you know [__] them
you know we have to go there to
straighten their problems out they
deserve it
what's up nope 101st not going
Ben said uh Eric Bana Eric Bano was
really good in this film yeah I liked
him in this although a lot of people
don't seem to like his performance I
read on Wikipedia that uh Ewan
McGregor's character in this movie whose
name was Grimes was actually he was like
a conglomeration of a couple of
different like the character that he was
the real guy that he was supposed to be
playing
um that real guy it turned out uh was
later convicted of raping his
six-year-old daughter so they didn't
want obviously they didn't want like
that character in the movie so they just
kind of changed it up a little bit but
yeah so that's why
um yeah straddock 78 said I remember I
rented Chopper and Blackhawk Down at the
same time it took me years to realize
Eric Bana starred in both movies he
looked so different
um Samantha said I love all the random
folks in this Ridley's Orlando Bloom and
uh Nikolai for his next movie kingdom of
heaven and then Ben said uh disclaimer I
have Blackhawk Down in 4k and I've
watched it a number of times Somalia has
untapped oil reserves that's the whole
reason the US was there yeah oh yeah
that tracks oh there's be more there was
more to it than that I guarantee you
something that CIA and Mi and so calm
Special Operations Command they had all
gotten together and then the military
industrial complex all the damn
corporations that were gonna few you
know all the corporations that were
going to fuel the Army for all their
equipment they was [__] was lining up
and they were like just there's we could
do something with this that's what they
were saying
but that whole
when when they came at it we didn't know
what they were interviewing us for it's
just based on what they were saying it
was bad we wanted nothing to do with it
it turned out to be this we were right
and it's funny how little e3s and e4s
can [__] predict how a whole [__]
war will go
well you know it's just it's not a good
like I said it's not a good situation
yes all around and really it was just
and there was some element and I don't
know how much of this was just like from
the movie or whatever but there was like
a little bit of element of like
overconfidence yeah at the beginning
it's like oh yeah it'll be so easy like
we just go in there and get the guys and
then all of a sudden all it took is like
one RPG like taken out of [__] you
know taking out the Blackhawk and yeah
and then it's just everything started
going like to [__] and then they
suddenly the whole city turned against
them and it's like they couldn't get to
the people and they were just all
getting [__] blown away yeah and RPG
is a rock a propelled grenade all right
it's just a damn launch tube and it's
got a Grenade it's about that long
it's or it's a rocket it's part it's
actually more of a more of a grenade
than it is a rocket an explosion to
launch it
throw it out kind of like a recoilless
rifle some of them have a little bit of
a rocket motor that'll thrust it for a
few seconds some some of them don't
depends on what load it is
but it's totally unguided it's some old
Soviet stuff based on some old German
stuff from World War II
the the launcher is only a couple
hundred bucks
brand new and they probably get a bit
cheaper than that on the international
arms Market but especially used
and the grenades in or the Rockets oh
man it's probably 50 bucks 100 bucks for
one of those no guidance systems none of
this high-tech [__] and they can shoot
down a helicopter with that yeah okay
why because you get good with it you get
good with it you don't I cannot stand
America's addiction to technophilia
their their technophiliacs where you
have to have something that can lock on
and [__] guide no no just good
tactics and good skills
[__] they were um Iraqi ferian
six guys a team of six that were trained
to take out tanks
I think the six guys took out a single
um M1 Abrams tank with just RPGs and
they did it by taking out the vision
ports a track they hit the track and
then they hit the vision ports and then
they got on top of it and just poured
gasoline down in into their character or
was it diesel fuel they poured diesel
fuel down certain sensitive spots and
set it on fire and just cooked all the
guys in there alive
you don't have to punch through armor
there are other ways and just skill you
know these are just these are Iraqis
Iraqi
Special Forces fetty they were pretty
good if they were in the right spot
skill and Manpower that really makes the
difference not technology like I said
you really can't underestimate yeah I
mean particularly when you're in like
when you're in someone else's territory
yeah uh and you know it's a home team
advantage that's what I mean and you're
surrounded essentially surrounded by
hostiles uh you know maybe they don't
have the technological [__] that you
have but obviously they don't need it in
a lot of uh in a lot of ways and I don't
know so I so I just feel like this whole
like this is a great movie but
um it's really
a bummer it's really a bummer because it
just seems like all of this [__]
happened and it didn't have to happen
like those people didn't have to die
those people didn't have to you know the
people that got wounded that's it's just
[__] up it just didn't happen at all
an aborted Mission yeah it just didn't
have to happen at all and it just seemed
like such a [__] waste yeah you know
what I mean it's just I think that's
what made me like the saddest about it
was that it was just a [__] weight of
of yeah of life you know what I mean all
these poor people and like I said it's
and that's not to Discount like the you
know the heroism and stuff like that
because yeah those dudes were they were
good they were [__] Brave man it's
like there's you know they knew they
were gonna get killed they're like yeah
we gotta go in there and get get our
buddies we got to get their bot even if
they knew they were dead they're like we
don't leave anybody behind so the fact
that they actually reduced that's
awesome I mean that's you know but and
they're good man for the US Army was
[__] good at that time real good
probably the best better than it was in
in their in in the second part of the
Iraq War
no man it's like a 90s 90s was the [__]
quality control was [__] Top Notch
for troops
troop recruitment was [__] top-notch
quality control it was Top Notch
only people who wanted to be there they
were [__] Pros man real good
[__] Rangers were the [__] beast
back in those days
I don't know what they're like now
probably nowhere near as what they used
to be
Special Forces isn't what it used to be
I kind of like
um the line that I guess of like Eric
bana's character says it in there where
it's it's almost like he didn't really
care about like the larger Mission or
anything like that he was basically
saying something to the effect of you
know our whole mission is just we just
have to like looking out for their
buddies you know what I mean you're just
defending the people that are fighting
with you and they're not really worrying
about yeah well those dudes knew that
this [__] was a cover story they're not
going to tell you why they were really
there
um
the US government wanted something there
they thought it was going to be easy but
it was going to be easy and it wasn't
worth whatever it was that they wanted
was worth it so then they just they
pulled out
yeah but what the that story of feeding
people
and no no it didn't they don't give a
[__] about that when have they ever
given a [__] about that
you know what I mean they'd be feeding
half Africa if they gave a [__] about
that that you know no they didn't care
about that but something else
this is what you told that's just what
they told Mom and Pop back home and the
troops
October raid said war is never good but
it's part of our DNA I don't think we
can change we're strange creatures yeah
I mean that's kind of a shame Jones
Perkins says great movie great podcast
well thank you very much ben says the
soundtrack of Black Hawk Down is also
top right yeah I really liked I think
Hans Zimmer did the score uh and he went
a little experimental with it which I
thought was really cool but yeah it had
like some uh good music in it as well he
said it had Joe Strummer from The Clash
and The Pogues and stuff like that so
yeah um but I don't know this just uh
I'm trying to think of like the other I
know there was like another criticism
that this got when it came out I think
that also the Malaysians and the
pakistanis were mad because they they
had like a much larger role in the
mission and in that whole situation than
they showed they really didn't show I
think they mentioned them and like at
the end like after they got back to the
soccer stadium or like to the safe Zone
like they had the Pakistani soldiers
like bringing them water and stuff but
you know I like I said I I feel like
when I was watching the documentary and
I don't remember if they mentioned this
in the at the beginning of the movie or
not but it was a bunch of Pakistani
peacekeepers that got killed that sort
sort of like turn the tide of the
somalis against like all these people
being there you know what I mean like
prior to that they weren't they weren't
really bothered because you know no one
was taking any sides as far as it went
but
after that happened and then there was
like a whole [__] and then this
whole [__] mission happened but I
mean as war movies go I think this is a
really really good because in a lot of
ways it's as realistic as they could you
know I guess likely make it when I was
watching it I was like holy [__] it
looks so much like
um you know what I remember of the news
footage like from Somalia and stuff like
that I was like obviously they didn't
shoot it there but um but I was like
where the [__] did they shoot this it
turns out they shot it in uh Morocco I
think they were gonna do it in Jordan
but they said well where they where they
wanted to shoot was like two built up so
they went to like they found some place
in Morocco and shot it because I was
like holy crap it looks really
uh accurate to at least what I remember
from the news footage at the time yeah
some of the stuff was a little
misleading to a civilian like they
showed a couple scenes where Chopper
Pilots put on nods which is nods are
what we call night vision devices
the goggles that you can see they're
they're usually a molecule monocle type
and that time it was probably the anpvs7
it's probably what they were using
um I've looked through pbs7s
every squad leader had one or t team
leader and squad leader had one in the
units that I was in and uh the way they
showed it is they showed it looks like
black and white
or excuse me a green and white or green
and black and white image
but when they show it in this they show
it as very clear
and that's not the way it really looks
usually it's kind of Muddy it's kind of
clear
but the the more light there is
in the field
the muddier it the image becomes
we never really used we never really
liked them
they're they're not they were not
Dependable it's and I think some of
these new video games give civilians
the idea that night vision is like
something that's real dependable and
that you have to have it and that
soldiers love it no we hated it we hated
it and didn't trust it they were good
for walking around navigation at night
through
um Darkness
as soon as firefights and [__] started
having tracers go out everywhere and in
this case they would have been in an
urban environment most of that [__]
would have been washed out you wouldn't
have seen much you didn't take the
goggles off
what's up bro what's the matter Pokey
and then you take the goggles off and
your eyes had been adjusted to that
image inside that nod
so now you're yeah it takes a long time
for your eyes to adjust to the normal
Darkness
and when you're young it's not as good
as now that I'm older but when you're
young your night vision can be developed
you could see real well at night
I don't know how I did it
but I used to be able to read by
moonlight
that's how good I got at that
well it's just like anything else you
would just get like uh indoor to it you
would get used to it I couldn't do it
now no my my night vision is getting
worse which it does as you get older you
know but by the by full Moonlight I
could read
in a printed page I couldn't do that now
no probably not
but I you know I I kind of feel like
that with with night vision and stuff
like that maybe you have to give them
some leeway for like a cinematic
experience you don't really want it to
be completely realistic because then
people would complain about that you
know what I mean yeah so
they'd be like well why is the rest of
the movie look all crisp and beautiful
and then we do the night thing yeah it's
a night vision it's all [__] up and
even though that's maybe what it would
really have looked like at the time yeah
but it looks okay when there's when it's
mostly dark but when there's a lot of
light light sources happening it starts
to muddy out
so I mean they kind of I feel like they
kind of went into that like toward the
end of the movie where he was trying to
get the that strobe thing and he was
trying to get it like up on the roof of
the building so the guys knew where it
was a Target does it feel like the
target designator thing like so yeah so
they would know where to hit it so I
kind of and you couldn't really see
because they're like look we can't
[__] see what's going on because
everybody's shooting at everybody and
there's fire everywhere and so it was
all like Whiting everything out
but yeah
um I don't know so I I really appreciate
Louie sending me this movie sending us
this movie because I don't think I saw
this at the time that it came out even
though yeah even though it was Ridley
Scott it seemed like something that I
probably would have gone to see but I
don't think I ever got around to seeing
it even though I always kind of wanted
to I actually sort of like forgot that
it was Ridley Scott until like later on
I never knew yeah but and he did get
nominated like I said for an Oscar for
this but he didn't win but he was
nominated it's a great war movie Best
Director it's a great war movie it yeah
I mean it really does immerse you in and
somebody pointed out they really like
the Practical effects in this yeah and
it's really
it stresses you out man I was like
stressed out watching this [__] movie
because it really seems like you're
really immersed it's almost like a first
person thing like a lot of it and then
just the way that people just get
[__] shot and it's just like it's
horrifying like I said I think that hand
like freaked me out the most like this
thumb flopping around because that
looked like really realistic and then
there was like the whole scene too where
they were where that guy got shot in the
thigh and they were trying to clamp off
his femoral artery yeah and that was
[__] [__] up as well the guy that
found a hand and just took it because he
just put it in like the pockets like oh
somebody might need this and I was like
man that is so [__] up
well I can understand the thinking yeah
I mean well yeah I'm never gonna be out
of there soon maybe they could reattach
that and it's probably good because you
never know you never know you know that
guy might appreciate that you picked it
up it's like it could have been like
well if we had the hand we could have
fit we could have saved it could have
saved we could have put it back on yeah
so you just to be safe better safe than
sorry just [__] take the hand yeah he
just like put in his bag like all calm
and [__] and like gonna need that yeah
Ben says remember the guy with the uh
unexploded shell stuck in his leg Yeah
and that one guy too like got an art
like a like a rocket like right in his
side like it killed him but like Ben
said leave no hands behind there's
there's a scene where a guy has a M16
with an m203 grenade launcher underneath
in this there's 16 jams up or he's out
of ammo I don't remember what it was he
might have been at it out of ammo M16s
basically didn't Jam
I never really saw that
um
so he engages some guys on the back some
engages some guys with a 40 millimeter
grenade launcher of an m203
and uh they're on the back of a flat big
truck with a 50 cal mounted to it and
they're struggling to reload the 50 cal
and he pops up and loads of 40 Mike Mike
round and [__] lobs it in and it
lands in front of him and blows them up
and they always get that 40 millimeter
grenade wrong
when you see those things in real he the
he versions
or HTTP which is high explosive Dual
Purpose that was the standard one that
they would give us
it was not impressive it looked like
some fireworks it went off it looked
like a flash Cube on an old-fashioned
camera yeah and uh but the the ball of
light would probably be about that big
around and then there'd be a little bit
of a concussion dirt around it you see
like a white if it was real humid you'd
see like a a white
concussive shock wave come out of it but
it wasn't impressive at all that thing
and as far as we knew it wasn't that
deadly we just used it to drive people
out of Dead Space if somebody was dead
space is a place where like a ditch
where everybody's laying down [__]
each other the lower you get
the less you could see them they're now
in your dead space you can lob something
it's called indirect fire you know you
can't directly see them so you lob it
indirectly into them you're driving them
out of Dead Space
so the guy will get up and run and you
can shoot him with direct fire that's
usually what that was used for you lob
it in through
front ends of bunkers and bunker windows
or Windows of buildings
but we never really expected that thing
to do any damage
When You See It Go off it's it's not
impressive but in the movies that [__]
[__] goes off big you know Boom Big
gasoline explosion well yeah like that's
the way you wished it went off that's
not how it goes off well like I said you
have to give them some leeway for like
yeah dramatic license you know what I'm
saying yeah she goes off it's like a
joke
you're like that's it actually I was
listening to that documentary and I was
listening to the a bunch of the guys
that were there and they said they were
all kind of like in one gathered you
know in one spot like kind of hiding out
and someone lobbed a grenade in there
and it said it landed like six inches
from this one guy's head
and it went off and they were all
freaking out so they're like they
couldn't see anything and there was like
just [__] sand everywhere and so it's
like they were calling out everybody to
see if they were okay and Collette was
the name of the guy that was his last
name that was the grenade Atlanta like
literally right by his head and they're
like oh man he didn't make it you know
what I mean because it just went off
right there but then they they said like
after a minute like everything went
quiet and he's just like yeah I'm okay
they're like how the [__] did that
happen well they said well this is like
because it was the grenade and they said
well it kind of blew upward yeah and
they were all kind of like down on the
ground so it's he's like nobody got
injured and we were just like amazed
that that had happened
you know what I mean because they're
like we thought that dude's had a gun
well you'd be surprised if everybody
were to just get down and lay down on
their bellies and start to look at each
other how everybody most the people you
wouldn't be able to see them right
because the Earth is not flat yeah not
at least well it is when you're around
tarmac and [__] you know what I mean but
in your if you're in nature it's not
very flat
so half the people disappear you're like
where are you because it you know
because there's slight bows and rolls to
the
to the ground you know
so that's enough to stop grenade
fragments
anything and you can't shoot at a person
yeah it's just again just kind of like
just simple [__] yeah
right it's worm's eye view everybody
disappears and [__] yeah
Richard Brown said a handbag yeah it was
a handbag yeah he just put it I just I
liked the way he was just kind of calm
about it he was just kind of like oh
well might need that you know what I
mean and I was like man that's so [__]
up just like the whole casual [__]
the way that he did it but you know why
he did it like I said because you never
know that dude might [__] need that
you know
um Jones Perkins says hey now in the
middle of this awesome review they're
denying the Flat Earth truth yeah yeah
the Flat Earth reality
uh yeah but uh but yeah so this is uh a
great flick uh if you you know it's one
of probably one of the best war movies I
mean there's a lot of good war movies
I'm not saying that it's one of the
better ones but this is definitely one
of the better ones and like I said
there's some inaccuracies but that's
true of any film
um I've heard the book is good I read a
book about this about the Battle of
mogadishi but I don't think it was the
one that this movie was based on you
know what I mean I kind of feel like it
was different because it was a long time
ago that I read it but I'm sure the book
is really good
too uh but yeah this is
um one of Ridley Scott's better movies I
thought you know just really well shot
um really exciting really [__] up
really tense it stressed me out like the
whole time not a lot of character
development and like I said I know
because there's so many characters
because the cast is so large like once
you get into like all the frenetic you
know battle scenes and everything like
that it's kind of hard to keep track of
where everybody's at and like who got
killed and [__] like that so and there's
no women but well yeah Ben just said
that women but um well like I said it's
based on our true story though and there
weren't any there so well that's but
yeah so
I don't know it's I was gonna say
something but then oh sorry yeah we were
out I threw her off if I just said
there's no women no because you
interrupt what you interrupted what I
was saying I'm trying to remember I
forgot what I was saying it probably
didn't matter I'm sure I'm sure it
didn't
nothing I say is important
I know well obviously it's not because
[Laughter]
[__] women but yeah well no I'm just
saying you'd be mad if I was just going
home if I interrupted you off if I
interrupt him he has like a flip out
about it I'm talking he goes no I don't
yeah you do yeah but it's like you know
but he interrupts me all the time and he
doesn't even think about it but um but
yeah definitely a great war movie we're
gonna have to like watch all the extras
and stuff like that on it because we
didn't have a chance to do that but we
did actually like watch it last night
and it's like really really good so if
you haven't seen it uh then give it a
watch and thank you very much again
Louie for sending it to us sorry it took
us so long to get to it but we finally
did uh so yeah
um all right so tomorrow is Monday which
means it's a haunting Mondays time and I
think we're going to revisit a haunting
in Florida which is what we were talking
about that last week that we wanted to
redo that one because like I said you
you know you know that guy and yeah [__]
like that and that's a good episode too
and like I said we're familiar with the
area so also instead of investors tell
them to redo it but that dude does not
want to be on the show now well you
can't blame him like I said he told me
he didn't want to talk about it anymore
he says Nah I want to talk about that
and the thing about is like that show
like a haunting in Florida that it was a
long time ago like that show I think it
first aired like back in 2006 or
something all his kids are grown now and
everything right so it's they're
probably just like yeah that's a long
that was a long time ago so I don't
blame him you know but where revisit the
episode anyway because that is an
episode that we like and you know it's
kind of an interesting one and like I
said it's an area that I'm pretty
familiar with because I grew up only
about 20 or 30 minutes from there from
where the house is so uh so yeah so
hopefully you guys can hang out with us
tomorrow evening at 7 30 for The
Haunting show and we will see you guys
then good night